whether you love it hate it or never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban presenting 2009's in any of
the year New York City Mayor Michael
Bloomberg remember his war on trans fats
we didn't just man
trans fats that's for sure he targeted
smoking too having already banned all
kinds of indoor smoking bloomie went
after the outdoor variety in 2009 oh and
you'd better hold the salt or meddling
Mike just might do it for you the mayor
is waging a war on salt and he wants
food manufacturers and restaurants to
join his army or else drinking soda is
just like drinking fat according to this
New York City Health Department ad
that's why the New York nanny wants to
slap soda with syntaxes and put down
those cupcakes you school kids the
city's health police has all but banned
school bake sales because sweets aren't
good for the kiddies this is her yard so
what's your new year's resolution mr.
mayor
banning whiskey from Manhattan's
mandating cheese free pizza tune in next
month for more examples of busybodies
minding your own business
[Music]